non communicable diseases are the
diseases that you and I are most
familiar with there are things like
diabetes and heart disease and
unfortunately I think that if you run
your hand over the planet you'll see
that in the poorest countries there's
extremely little that's being done
across these dimensions these diseases
are not getting the attention that they
deserve and yet they are becoming a
larger and larger piece of the puzzle of
Public Health so in Rwanda and Kenya and
Ethiopia in a number of countries where
I've worked over the years we've seen
large numbers of new type 1 and type 2
diabetes coming through the door just a
couple months ago
I was out at a Health Center where a man
who was suffering with type 1 diabetes
was actually living at the Health Center
because he didn't have the authority to
provide himself with daily injections of
insulin of course this would never
happen in the US or in a rich country he
get his needles and he get his insulin
and he'd be able to inject himself at
home but where there is care that's
given it's given without very much
instruction or very much knowledge of
these diseases one of the perhaps best
interventions that we can make as a
world today in the area of Public Health
is around these non communicable
diseases we've actually got to start
taking a look at heart disease in poor
countries I know that in China for
example heart disease has become one of
the top killers in Rwanda and
sub-saharan Africa heart disease is a
major killer but it's a bit of a silent
killer because people haven't tracked it
over the years it hasn't been as
interesting nor has it attracted as much
donor dollars as something like aids
tuberculosis or malaria and yet it's
still claiming a huge number of lives
and a lot of productivity even though we
don't have the best of baseline data we
do know that the impact is enormous and
we know that with changing diets and
poor countries with urbanization with
increase in smoking and basically bad
rich country habits people are going to
beginning sicker and sicker earlier and
earlier and now is the time to really
prevent this disease which is going to
be the next
wave of pandemic that hits the world